usa el símbolo de menor o de mayor en el
espacio marcado por estos paréntesis
para que esto sea correcto o sea
básicamente lo que quieren es que
digamos si este número es mayor que este
o si este número es menor que este y
entonces para que sea más claro pues
vamos a escribirlos aquí en grandote a
ver el primer número
45.67 5 o sea 45 unidades seis décimas
siete centésimas y cinco milésimas y por
otro lado está el número cuarenta y
cinco 45 punto
45 ósea y 45 unidades y 600 45 milésimas
ahora si se fijan en el lugar de las
escenas y en el lugar de las unidades
estos dos números son iguales entonces
como la parte entera estos números son
iguales
cuál es mayor que el otro depende de la
parte a la derecha del punto entonces
veamos en la parte de los decimales
también son iguales entonces vamos a
pasar al lugar de las centenas y aquí en
este lugar de las centenas ya no son
iguales 7 es mayor que 4 y entonces ya
con eso 45.67 5 es mayor que 45 puntos
64 5 entonces aquí va un signo de mayor
qué